[Music]
bitcoin has become a popular mainstream
investment
but it's also known for its volatility
you don't know if in a week's time the
value will be 20
lower 10 lower 10 higher
its value fluctuates so much that few
people would use it to buy everyday
goods such as shampoo or a plane ticket
some crypto entrepreneurs say there's
one way to change that
stable coins die this is a really
interesting one
usd coin or usdc stable coins are
different from other cryptocurrencies
and that they are pegged to assets like
the us dollar or gold
which is meant to make them more stable
they've grown particularly popular
among traders online in just a year as
bitcoin hit new records
the market value of stablecoins has
grown tenfold
facebook has announced plans to launch
its own stablecoin
and visa said it would create a
stablecoin credit card
but a probe of one staplecoin exposed
some potential risks with this system
it's tether the new york attorney
general had accused tether
the most popular staple coin of lying
about the cash reserves it uses to
guarantee its dollar peg
tether did not deny nor admit wrongdoing
as part of a 2019 settlement but agreed
to release quarterly statements
detailing its reserves
so can stable coins accelerate the
adoption of cryptocurrencies in our
daily lives
and will they change the way we pay for
goods
according to its creators bitcoin was
meant to allow direct payments without
ever going through banks
but so far it's been accepted by few
companies with very few high profile
exceptions like tesla
market analysts found that bitcoin's
price has at times jumped or crashed by
as much as six
thousand dollars in a day but that
hasn't been the case for stable coins
in the past year the value of top stable
coins has fluctuated by as much as four
cents to their one dollar pegs
you can have reasonable assurance that
in you know three months time or six
months time
or one week's time it'll still be worth
a hundred dollars
and that's what was missing in crypto
before stable coins came along
alex kern is an analyst who researches
stable coins and other cryptocurrencies
he says the first stable coins were
created as early as 2014.
the 24-hour trading volume is often over
90 billion
bitcoin is a little over 50 billion so
it trades more often than bitcoin
tether was pegged to the us dollar and
more than 200
other staple coins followed some pegged
to the euro
or to the korean wan others to
commodities like gold
silver or oil or a combination of
different assets
on top of stability stable coins like
tether have another key advantage
speed because this is digital money
transactions go through in a matter of
seconds
faster than the three days it usually
takes to wire us dollars or euros
using traditional banks stable coins are
also faster than bitcoin because the
payments are centralized and managed by
the company that created them
for example tether transactions are
managed by the tether platform
while bitcoin payments are processed by
a vast decentralized network of people
called miners who are spread out all
over the world
it's instantaneous there's no settlement
process that needs to occur
only a handful of e-commerce websites
accept stable coins at the moment
but crypto traders have quickly adopted
stable coins like tether to buy and sell
cryptocurrencies online
that's because stable coins don't run on
normal banking hours
compared to stocks that have to be
traded in locations like new york or
hong kong during specific hours
cryptocurrencies are traded 24 hours a
day seven days a week
all across the globe plus academics who
study the role of cryptocurrencies
say some banks have been wary to
interact with crypto exchanges due to
the lack of oversight in the industry
and concerns that they could be exposed
to illicit activities like laundering
money or funding terrorism
finance one of the largest
cryptocurrency exchanges in the world
said it is committed to creating a
compliance safe and reliable trading
environment
and it asks users to follow all local
laws on money laundering
and counter terrorism financing
in 2019 the new york attorney general
accused the companies managing the
stablecoin tether
also called usdt of making false
statements to investors
about the cash reserves of its currency
an essential component of what makes it
stable and secure for investors
the crypto community online discussed
the probe and tethers dollar backing
if you go to their website right here it
says every tether is always 100
backed by our reserves which sounds very
much as if one us dollar went in
and a tether was printed in return it's
so simple
the investigation found that in 2017 and
2018
beatfinnex a cryptocurrency exchange
that is common ownership with the
company that controls tether
relied on a third-party company named
crypto capital corporation
to handle deposits and withdrawals on
beat finex's trading platform
the new york attorney general's office
said that crypto capital corporation
failed to process some of these orders
and b finex lost
access to 850 million dollars of its
customers money
crypto capital said it couldn't process
beat finex transactions
because in 2018 its bank accounts in the
us
poland portugal and the united kingdom
were frozen without justification
naturally this significantly delayed
fiat withdrawals from bitfenix for its
users
which started to suspect something was
up the new york attorney general's
office said beat fenex tapped into
tethers dollar reserves
to cover up the losses and afterwards
lied to its customers
when it said its currency was fully
backed by u.s dollars at
all times during the course of the new
york attorney general's
investigation tether said it held 74
of the necessary reserves which some
investors considered to be enough to
make the digital currency secure
this is perfectly common in modern
banking in which only a fraction of bank
deposits are backed by
actual cash on hand as part of a
settlement with the new york attorney
general's office
beef and x and tether limited paid 18.5
million dollars in penalties
and stopped trading activity with new
yorkers this
is finally coming to an end beefinex and
tether said the amount of money they
agreed to pay
should be viewed as a measure of their
desire to put the matter behind them
the firms did not admit or deny any
wrongdoing
industry insiders say this investigation
should be a warning to all companies
that created stablecoins
and to expect the stablecoin industry to
be more tightly regulated in the coming
years
some companies already looking towards a
future of using reliable virtual money
as payments
visa announced a stablecoin based credit
card and said that making its digital
currency strategy secure
private and trusted is a key priority
facebook's new cryptocurrency project dm
aims to create stable coins pegged to
different fiat currencies
dm says the system is being built with
security in mind
some countries are also working on what
financial analysts call the next
iteration of stable coins
which would be a digital currency pegged
to the national currency
and controlled by central banks but
before this type of digital money truly
goes mainstream
kern says its creators and issuers are
going to have to convince regulators and
users that their technology will keep
their money safe
it's going to be very important for
people to trust the entity
that's issuing the stable coin and the
one that has the most trust of people
over a period of time
be the one that becomes the most heavily
used
you